welcome to this video playing FM chromis
from hmm iceland norway yeah sorry to
all those yeah I know Iceland is not
Scandinavian but I really screw up those
flags okay um we have an English opening
and f-fire film now here you can
actually go default atom chip to g5
that's one idea yeah be sure to defy
their deserts you can play it it's not
the end of the world for black but you
can play it know him so hmm to d2 or
well what do you wanna do you one better
maybe g1 I like to get it on get it to
f4 quickly yeah okay
you
yeah my development is some is a bit
damn it slow of course
mmm yeah but I can it's this bed I think
it looks like i would assume that this
should be quite okay for what
I take take g5 and rope to see one or
take take multiple times at Roxy one
Queen a form i can he can always drop
bag I would still it's not bad at all
Bishop f7 I can also just them okay
didn't do that I want to say to I can
always secure the night yeah g3 is
probably not necessary move at the mode
yeah this is a really strange movie I
thought briefly about that but why the
only idea is really if I don't see that
the Queen Hanks otherwise it just dumb
weakens the whole go inside the belief
it's it's just just bad really what it
is doing besides weakening yourself okay
maybe a three still and then look see
one coming the only bad thing about this
is that the Queen so it would be nice if
the Queen would be behind the rook and
not the vice versa yeah my goal is to
further strengthen this he wants to
probably put the knight on d5 now this
would actually help a bit hmm yeah okay
how to proceed
if I let him take them it's not a big
deal maybe make big play this first and
term and now just to get one
I just don't want to get rid of the
rooks I probably played this to tame
some hot now 22 to win yeah play let's
play this too tame okay yeah Walter team
is not proper english to team leave this
sounds really strange yeah whatever not
today not active enough or something
don't tell me I'm actually worse here
this would be would be UT where'd but
okay edge form
okay keep it for the moment yeah wow
this was really bad game by me I mean
those moves like be 50 really atrocious
I mean it and I'm the food the one with
the passive position now
check
don't it's a problem still very draws
and tending to five
I mean yeah he must be a bit cautious
even to not allow too much activity his
King is also exposed I can move let's
gamble it a bit opening up the position
and see how he defends d 5 f-5 and so on
also g7 week now if it takes h5 i KF
Queenie 6
yeah I hope I'm not risking too much
here why the check first yeah it's also
check check check check yeah how to how
to win this now okay okay okay maybe go
go ahead with the King to e5 yeah maybe
he played this a bit too ambitious Ling
I don't know it's it's just a drawing
probably should be at wrong with with
the Kings and I mean this was just
hoping that yeah this now it's a bit
more tricky for black to play it's still
probably draw but you can you can go
wrong and I don't think I risked much
really yeah I don't know I when I want
lots of material with check and not like
extra material at the end but i get i
get some some things yeah adapt to data
that i really got this position SS it's
just bad i mean how wrong would you why
would you play b5 adjust the weekends
but i did edit some some bad things as
well of course for example this is not
good just play Queen c3 c3 2d to Roxy
one or prepare with a three or something
and then put the look on c5
at the end I I lost time and with with
with 925 you really repair this position
now there's not much going on and this
is just down just a draw yeah okay
thanks for watching